to former conservative politician author
louise mensch louise mensch you're a
conservative member of parliament you
know boris johnson i don't know how much
you believed of all his denials about
partygate but this picture
series of pictures released tonight
seemed to me that even for the most
devoted boris supporters
to be the the nail in the coffin
of his persistent lies about these
parties that's him at a party he said
never happened drinking with bottles
everywhere food everywhere having a
party
unfortunately piers that's not exactly
what he said and if you roll the tape
and go back to the clip that you had at
the top of the show there he was asked
do you remember this party on the 13th
of november or can you confirm there was
this party on the 13th of november
whatever the date was and he looked
blank and said no he didn't as you just
said as you characterized it issue some
sort of affirmative denial it was clear
that he didn't really know what she was
he said all the rules
he said all the rules had been followed
and yet he knew that's what he knew he'd
been at that party on a day when he
himself with his own rules had ordered
that no gathering of more than two
people could happen inside
his rules let me tell you he broke them
did he let me tell you something about
lying to the house
let me tell you something about lying to
the house of commons peers you have to
do it intentionally you can't
accidentally lie to the house of commons
you have to say something that you know
is false at the time that you say it if
he believed that he wasn't breaking the
rules and trust me the prime minister
doesn't set these things up himself he
doesn't keep his own diary he would have
got advice from civil servants you can
go to this leaving
they would know they were his rules
they were his rules
here's let's remember these photographs
may be new because don cummings or his
friend have given them to the newspapers
but they're not new to the police i
think the key point about these
photographs is that downing street said
that sue gray the metropolitan police
had these photographs all along they
knew about them they maybe knew on the
front page they may be new to the
tabloids but then here's the problem
here's the problem that's happening
tonight which is you you've got former
deputy police commissioners of the met
police coming out tonight saying that
they think this is very disturbing
because they think it shows potentially
the police have not done their job
properly because it seems such a de
facto prime of facey breach of the rules
and they're very concerned so the police
may come under huge pressure now to try
and explain why apparently other people
at that event have received fines but
not boris johnson who appears to be
leading him
and you know what i can't tell you that
that is a matter for the police i
noticed though that forgive me but
you've shifted ground you've already
acknowledged that the police did have
these photographs so if the prime
minister was not fined and he knows
perfectly well the police have had these
photos all along they've been part of
their investigation
it's just something that dom cummings
has put out because he can't stand boris
johnson it doesn't matter where they
came from why does it matter where it
came from
in advance of the sue grey reports these
things have come out to make the
headlines but you've got no evidence
that the prime minister knowingly lied
to the house at all and i'm literally
looking at a guy
this is from kids
i'm literally i've literally just played
a clip let's play it again
that's the picture and here's what he
said about that party when he was asked
about it in parliament
the prime minister tell the house
whether there was a party in downing
street on the 13th of november
mr speaker no but i'm sure that it would
ever happen the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed at all times
the guidance and the rules were followed
even though he knew that that was in the
middle of a second lockdown when he went
to that podium every single day and
reminded us no gatherings inside of more
than two people so i'm afraid he's a
liar whichever way you try and spin it
louise and admire the loyalty the guy
likes parliament i don't know he lied to
the british people and i'm afraid i
think his position because of this these
release of these pictures could very
quickly become untenable senior tories
tonight are talking out against him
scottish conservative party leader
saying is completely unjustifiable other
tory mps turning on him i'm just
surprised you're not
i don't know the man personally but i
know what i just heard and he was asked
can you confirm that this happened he
said no he didn't say it definitely
didn't happen clearly if you look at the
clip he didn't remember it and honestly
we both know piers that boris johnson is
a very ambitious man he is if you like
he's a very disingenuous man but he's
he's a bit self-centered now why would
he knowingly risk his premiership over a
plastic glass full of warm water why was
somebody who's why would somebody who's
and so he did it why would somebody
who's been
fired from previous jobs for lying
several jobs for lying
lie again is that the question you
wanted me to ponder
no i just want you to ask yourself if
you just look purely at his
self-motivation he gets his guidance
from civil servants who keep his diary
actually i would say his motivation
was he lying i would say his motivation
was very straightforward he didn't want
to lose his job as prime minister so he
lied about the parties that's the
motivation that i see on boris johnson
is that somebody who thought he thought
like he's done his entire career he
could just wing it and be economical
with the truth and he'd get away with it
and he would have done with this except
that pictures tell a thousand stories
you cannot look at these pictures and
then play that clip and not deduce in my
opinion that the prime minister of this
country lied to parliament and that
is an offence where you lose your job
it is if you knowingly lie to parliament
yeah again it goes back to you say these
are very serious i say to you the police
had them all along and the police did
not decide and i would say that raises
questions for the police which i i think
are going to get very hot louise mensch
i appreciate you joining me thank you
very much indeed thank you